hello my name is
a student of West Bengal University of
Health Sciences in the department of
bachelor in medical laboratory
technology
so today I am going to discuss about my
project title which is the
identification of metagenomic taxonomy
and the role of micro environment in God
I respect and thank Dr raghavenders
for providing me an opportunity
to do the project work
during microbiome comprises of bacteria
Alicia viruses you can use that results
within an outside of our body
the unique diversity of human microbiota
accounts for specific metabolic
activities and functions microorganisms
within our body
it is therefore
important to understand the microbial
composition and activities of human
microbiome as they contribute to health
and disease
the aim of the project and the skills
that I have used to identify whether the
microbiota
targeted diets can positively impact
human biology we have performed a
dietary intervention
while longitudinally monitoring the
microbiome change in the healthy adults
here we will study the effects of two
diet fermented and fiber using
metagenomics profiling
by crime to Downstream analysis of
sustainous amplicon data using R to find
out the microbial abundance and
microbial diversity
these were the questions
that I asked to myself while making this
project what is the effect of gut micro
how does diet affect the gut myself
but that was given to the participants
the relationship between the
cut microbes and the immune system
so this is how the entire research was
conducted the uh samples were taken from
a PubMed publication publication number
is given
in that publication they took healthy
they took healthy adults for a 10 minute
dietary intervention 17 weeks to be
precise free and post intervention
Counting
two types of that was given either High
permanent or high fiber
out of 38 participants that participated
in that study we have taken the first
Fifth and the ninth which tool sample
assess their microbiota composition
and six samples of each food groups were
chosen randomly during my studies
the study comprises of understanding the
gut microbes and its effects on immune
system
and we have used metagenomic tools like
time to and data to focus this purpose
now the method
used during this data analysis
was taken from T info wire server for
metagenomic and phylogenetic analysis of
gut microbes present in the fecal
samples
time 2 pipeline was used for breaking
down the metagenomous data producing
operational taxonomic unit that is otu
and denizing methods producing amplifier
sequence variant that is ASB
we use R coding for analyzing of
microbial abundance and diversity to
have used simple statistical methods
like means median to find out the
overall proportionals abundance of
various Pilots classes
family Etc over the time period of nine
weeks in both I fiber and high fermented
that you have studied
Alpha diversity and beta diversity using
checkered Emperor brake artists and
Alpha diversity box plot method
Alpha diversity is the measure of a
diversity in a single sample based on
the number and relative abundance of
taxa
in some ranks
the microbial emergency based on Shannon
and child diversity
based on the diet does not show any
significant change but
Canon and child diversity based on time
points shows some change in microbial
diversity
in some sample the otus
based on the alpha diversity
shows there is higher abundance of
microbial community in fermented diet as
compared to fiber diet
beta diversity is another name of sample
dissimilarities it quantifies
difference in overall taxonomy
composition between samples
where we use two methods break artists
and checkered Emperor and both shows the
microbiota composition difference
between the first week and the Nitric
samples
abundance between first week and 9th
grade samples are different
in order to represent
two dimensional plots from huge
interspace distance Matrix we are doing
taxonomy abundance plot taxonomy
awareness plot is similar to Beta
diversity the above three groups marked
in of phylum bacterial
DTS class bacteriodia as
some unclassified genus of species which
is more abundant in
people having fiber diets compared to
fermented diet one group marked at the
bottom of class bacterial disease
of phylum batteryologies and class
bacteriodia
helps uh unclassified genus and species
that only uh shows growth in people
consuming
fermented that
now we have explored the data and
visualized it we have also done some
tests for statistical indications
finding mean and median values
here in the ninth week sample of actino
bacteria of fiber diet we have seen
three samples
had complete
complete missing the missing abundance
of actuino bacteria
and three samples that also give the
results
in that in
in there also
uh two samples were given just less than
one percentage abundance
and here we have understand the role
that photography and actinobacteria
play in the god
the role of Photography is
is playing in gut health and wireless
bacterial bacteria plays a pivotal role
in development and maintenance of God
homeostasis
here we have studied the major taxonomic
groups that is bacteriodalis orders
prostudia
classes family and Latino Spira family
and their abundance in fiber and versus
fermented and also calculated their mean
value
here we have understood how unclassified
taxonomy
as placed in all gut microbes
there are many unclassified uh families
present in fermented diet which is more
than
pivot that and then genus also there are
more unclassified genus present in the
fermented that then the in the fiber
diet
and here are the list of analysis that
we have done and their abundance level
is mentioned on this
table
fiber versus fermented
now we'll come down to the result and
interpretation
we have found out that the levels of
bacteria differ from sample to samples
the above tables that I have shown
the representation of the entire data
during this analysis
there is a higher abundance of microbes
in gut of people consuming fiber that at
the ninth week Mark less abundance of
unclassified families and cleanups in
fiber dirt and more abundance of other
unclassified
families and genus in fermented that
photography plays a key role in cartels
while as actinobacteria plays a pivotal
role in development and maintenance of
gut homeostasis
and the conclusion
is that both
high fiber and high fermented diet has
certain advantages and disadvantages
I in fermented that provides more
abundance of gas microbes over the nine
weeks the loss of actinobacteria in the
ninth week in some hyper high fiber diet
leads to this uh leads to disturbance
and of development of development of gut
homeostasis
and also the maintenance of gothamia
stresses
nearly 60 to 70 percent of the microbes
presenting either fermented or Fiber
that is referred as unclassified species
so it is very hard for us to tell
how the gut microbes impact our immune
system and the further research should
be carried out in discovering these
unclassified
family Geniuses and species